Amongst us in our homes and close to the food we eat,...
...live some mysterious tiny, yet extremely energetic creatures.
Much smaller.
These are microorganisms, extremely small living beings.
There are three different types of microorganisms.
The good ones help to produce foods and drinks such as cheese and yoghurt,...
...fermented meat and fermented vegetables.
Some other microorganisms are annoying.
These are the bad ones.
They are responsible for the foul smell,...
...bad taste and repulsive look of rotting food.
But they normally don't cause diseases.
But it's the other kinds of microorganisms that we really need to be afraid of!
They don't cause food to smell bad and they don't change the way it looks.
They are the dangerous ones and it's necessary to be very careful with them.
These are known as pathogenic microorganisms and they can cause severe illnesses...
...such as stomach pains, vomiting, diarrhea, fever and even death!
They are deceitful, invisible and dangerous.
These tiny beings are very, very prolific.
To increase in number they need food, water, time and warmth.
They can multiply very quickly.
Fortunately, no matter how strong and frightening these microorganisms are,...
...they are preventable and vulnerable.